Hi, this is Briana from freeCodeCamp
and today we're going to talk a little bit about
binary code.
Now binary code is a really really basic simple
computer language where there's just
1's and there's 0's.
There's bi (two things), 1's, and 0's.
1's meaning on.
0's meaning off.
So think of like a light switch, which in some cases
super old computers there was an actual switch
which was either on or off.
1 being on. 0 being off.
Bunch of 1's and 0's. They can mean pretty much
anything, but really they're mostly meant to be
numbers and letters.
We're going to go in a little bit on how you actually
decode binary or translate a number to binary code.
But really as you guessed, you can usually just Google
binary translator and have that figured out.
The most important part of this:
Do you understand the concept that even basic things
like 0's and 1's can translate into something
really really complex.
And it is the basis for all the computer languages
and programs that exist today.